n'oublions pas que les territoires
ultramarins ont une histoire
particulière et que le rapport à l'État
français t'as pas toujours été simple
dans l'ensemble de ces territoires qui
composent notre République l'expression
étatique notamment par le biais de la
justice ce pouvoir régalien devrait donc
être d'autant plus irréprochable dans
cette territoire ultramarins ici d'un
passé colonialiste qui nous oblige
pourtant la situation partagée sur
l'ensemble du territoire national et que
dans sa fonction Gallienne de la justice
l'État
est loin d'être parfait disons-le
simplement ainsi les états généraux de
la justice qui ont été rappelés à
plusieurs reprises dans notre débat font
état d'une crise profonde de notre
système avec une justice au bord de la
rupture dans certains domaines avec des
délais de jugement et des conditions
pour l'ensemble des acteurs et des
justiciables qui deviennent parfois
indécents ce climat entraîne une
défiance croissante de nos concitoyens
vis-à-vis de la justice française c'est
dire l'impasse dans laquelle nous
pouvons nous retrouver
cette justice garante du respect du
droit malgré et vous avez raison
monsieur le ministre des hausses
incontestable de crédit cette justice
reste en difficulté tellement nous
partons de loin cela est d'autant plus
vrai en Outremer à le thermomètre de
l'outre-mer montre que nous avons encore
beaucoup d'efforts et vous ne les avez
pas nier je tiens à vous en remercier
mais nos exigences sont aussi à prendre
en considération ne les prenez pas comme
étant entre guillemets des remises en
cause du pouvoir adjectif actuel mais
comme simplement la reconnaissance de
difficultés au plan local les
territoires d'outre-mer sont trop
souvent peu ou mal considérés par nos
politiques publiques et ça ne date pas
effectivement de ce gouvernement
nous réagissons souvent trop avec un
prisme hexagonal reconnaissons-le dès
lors l'adaptation de nos dispositifs
n'est pas toujours optimal par ailleurs
le comité des états généraux de la
justice indique que les caractéristiques
démographiques et socio-économiques des
Outre-mer les distingue
significativement de la métropole ainsi
le taux de pauvreté et on sait bien que
pauvreté et délinquance peut avoir des
liens malheureusement ce taux de
pauvreté que le taux de chômage sont
particulièrement élevés face à un coût
de la vie et d'accès au bien de première
nécessité exponentielle par rapport à
celui de l'Hexagone toutes celles et
tous ceux ici qui ont qui connaissent
l'outre-mer même s'il n'y habit pas
savent ces difficultés et ce que le
représente parfois en termes de
délinquance toutes ces inégalités
doivent être prises en compte ainsi que
les spécificités liées à l'éloignement
de ces territoires et leur particularité
géographique il n'est pas possible de se
dire qu'en 2023 justiciables n'ont pas
tous et toutes les mêmes droits et les
mêmes accès aux droits nous nous
réclamons de l'État de droit or la
justice et la clé de voûte de ce système
seul l'état est à même d'exercer cette
fonction afin d'en garantir
l'impartialité or dans les territoires
ultramarins je conclus madame la
Présidente nos collègues ont pu exposer
aujourd'hui les failles de ce service
public